[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
would you ever date your mom
oh definitely not
first of all she's older than me second
of all she's my mom well why
i'm your mom and you're my son
and i and falling in love with him he
said are you really i said yes i am he
said you know what
i was scared to let you know too i am
too for both consenting adults if if uh
it comes down to it you know it's just
like the gays they're you know
as long as they're over 18 everything's
fine you know what i mean the us wants
to jail them for 18 months well that'll
fix it they got arrested they actually
got arrested oh well they should
definitely arrest him who gives a [ __ ]
if you want to [ __ ] your mom that's our
point
that's true
i don't care i can't i don't care at all
but i think it's that that he wants to
marry his mom there comes the legality
he's a [ __ ] yeah she's got a tattoo on
her face yeah you say go for it look
once you have a baby too
your tits get mushy that's it that's
just it's nature so what should i do
should i hoist them up should i have
them reduced don't talk about it first
of all yeah keep that [ __ ] to yourself
but no women are gonna have kids and our
population is gonna die off
[Laughter]
cinnabons you buy at the grocery store
sure i love those those are good those
are so good
look how thin you are thank you bastard
i've been working thinner than burt
still i think oh the bird went right
back
did you see
how i mean like we had
i want to show you this this is like
people would call in
or like send in videos saying bird is
fat in different languages
this is amazing
why is this so fast
but crusher you are a fat [ __ ]
you're a fat i can't than tom segura
might and then
this was my internet favorite thing
this was amazing people that listen to
the podcast that teach english as a
second language would use
the whole fat battle to teach english
abroad in in different countries so
this is in india
[Applause]
in japan
[Music]
oh my god
doesn't go to the gym
[Laughter]
oh i know oh she's got crown in a bowl
it's a friend it's a friend she's like
i'm not in a relationship a friend did
this for me friend what a nice guy well
listen i would say honey uh i'll come in
the bowl for you but honestly the best
way is to suck it out the way you get it
all right i mean just for your sake
i have a feeling a lot of guys feel that
way too let me watch this i know this is
important i'm not into watching people
eat comments i know it's weird because
outside of porn it's disgusting i think
in porn by the way when it's like eight
dudes in the glass that is [ __ ]
gnarly oh this is my favorite i have
i those them all bookmarked
oh there's not enough guys only eight
guys
she's hungry feed her and it's so like
you can tell the real savages in porn
who are just like
at the cleveland improv once like i was
that was grinding through a rough set
and this guy in the third girl goes uh
he goes
that's terrible man i get like fully
loud like this guy is terrible
what's up man and then some lady in the
back goes your mama should have
swallowed that nut like meaning like is
it cleveland yeah at the cleveland
improv wow i was like damn yeah i go
your dad should have stuck around to
raise you and then
and then like i got out of there pretty
quick
where are you most excited about to go
on this tour i like texas well i mean i
just i like going places where it's fun
yeah there's something about connecticut
that's just bleak yeah there's like a
lack of opportunity there's just
something bleak about it it's it's
almost like an illegitimate state it's
like a highway between boston and new
york that's really what it is and it
always feels like that when you're there
just feels
weird like there's a lot like almost
like there's a sadness that permeates
the show even when they're laughing
i went out to a restaurant they had a
water menu i it depends on how high i am
yeah if i was really high i'd be like
what's going on yeah but if i was sober
i'd be like [ __ ] you i'm leaving of
course but if you're really high you
might be like bring one of everything
let me try all this [ __ ] try your water
man yeah fort lauderdale the hollywood
improv yeah i always had a good time
there the seminole yeah yeah that was
for me i mean that's when i was like
coming up whatever yeah that was harder
the bluetooth everyone the bluetooth oh
those bluetooth tie pieces remember
those guys
are you talking to my phone
and then all the talking during your set
those things stopped they ended yeah
thank god isn't that weird do you know
of ryan sickler's story about that i
know so he had a uh he needed a tape for
something
and so ryan zigler is one of my good
friends very funny comic setup you know
what it's like when you're taping a set
for something you want everything to
come together right so he sets up a
camera in the back of the hollywood
improv and
records
his own set and he's up there
having a great set killing leave stage
like i got i got my set to submit to
whatever thing he's sending it in for a
comedy set or something
so he's just happy he gets back to
review it and
a guy sitting next to the camera the
tripod with the camera as soon like as
ryan gets on stage he's like hello
huh
comedy club
comedy i'm at a comedy club and
throughout ryan's set you just hear the
guy
on his phone call he keeps
saying over and over com comedy club
i'm at a comedy club
i mean you've said this before is that
you'd prefer hungry tits over big fakers
yeah any day hungry hungry little ones
yeah that won't need to be fed yeah
i would rather give spoonfuls of just
pasta to those hungry tits then yeah i
don't like big fakers so do you think
that it's also like part of the reason
why she accepted this
position in life in the first place it's
like there's like a
like a pragmatism like a cold pragmatism
like this is a good move
of course yeah well she was a hot chick
right she's like a model so that's what
you got to do it's uh you know you can't
model forever pictures of her in a
lesbian sort of photo shoot type thing i
know there's some nude modeling yeah
there's some she did some new modeling
good looking lady you know
there's nudie pics of our first lady
that's crazy that's crazy
it'd be crazy if there was like butthole
picks you know right if she like did
spread them shots yeah it looks like a
string of spit yeah
[Laughter]
and we're back to your mom
cleveland seems to have made a comeback
though cleveland's doing and i you know
improv i've had great shows in that city
that i i
but that club cleveland improv i
definitely had some
[ __ ]
really bad crazy shows
i mean there was a guy arrested
during the show
who he sent back because it says one
pound of chicken wings and he goes that
one a pound
and they're like that's what it is man
he's like take me to the kitchen
and weigh weigh them because i know
that's not a pound oh my god and they
have a by the way this is one of the
clubs that there's a permanent police
officer
stationed in the lobby
and so they're like no he's like well
i'm not paying for it so they just get
the cop
and they go hey here's the deal and the
cop goes look thinking like this is
look man you're either paying for them
take you to jail and the guy just goes
there you go
go ahead
so they arrest him wow over an order of
chicago so you didn't want to pay for it
wow is this not a pound that was dude
the cleveland improv you've had merch
stolen off your table i had merch stolen
at the cleveland
who stole your merch these people like
they're like we want a picture and they
like totally distracted me and then when
i looked down i was like doing my own
thing then like you know i have 20 of
these there's like five gone but they
just set me up for a picture and then i
turned back and they were gone like wow
did you know who the people were did you
see them leave did you go after that i
mean i it's like i turned and i was like
hey i'm telling like the security guy
like they just stole and he was like
yeah it sucks man
like it wasn't like we're gonna pursue
this
you know
what it is man people steal [ __ ]
there was a
new york nick i forget his name
and they were interviewing him about you
know these nba contracts are bananas oh
yeah it's fully guaranteed it's one of
the leagues that has fully guaranteed
money so not like the nfl where it's
like you have this much guaranteed the
rest of that you're not getting that
[ __ ] so nba whatever you know there's
salary caps and he played out one of his
contracts and they're like we want to
keep you but we can't give you like top
end money so you're going to get 9
million for next year and then his first
interview with the press he was like i
mean you know
it's going to be tough but i'll see what
you know i'll try to make it happen and
they're like it's going to be tough to
survive on that he was like pretty much
yeah
i mean i have a family
9 million man
everybody i know that loves their act is
terrible everybody everybody tells me oh
my new stuff's amazing i love it like
ugh get away from me yeah it's gross
i remember remember we did a show one
time where that guy was like
don't you love going back and watching
yeah yeah some guys like don't you love
watching yourself i'm like it was
terrible it was terrible there you go
that's always the case yeah it's weird
it's always the case and they're they're
always like big self-promoters too oh
god yeah yeah letterman hated himself i
read some book about him years ago and
every episode he would go home and just
put on the hair shirt and flog himself
like that was the worst episode ever and
i in my estimation he's the best i love
herman so much but he that's why he's
the best though yeah he's because he had
these high standards he wasn't just
half-assing it yeah yeah yeah it's true
i remember a guy one time asked me to
get him a guest spot and it's like i
went to a city and he was like i knew
him i met him before
so i talked to the manager of the club
and i was like can i get this guy a
guest spot and she was like are you
vouching for him
yeah
so he goes okay
so
he goes up there just eats
such a big bag of [ __ ] so then the club
manager was like what the [ __ ] was that
and i go well i just i don't know so
there's a second show and i go dude that
was like you know he was like
i'll do a totally different set on the
sega totally different set and and i'll
i'll make up for it and i go okay
so i go let's just let him he'll do a
totally different set that was just oh
no and then not only does he do
the same set he does ex verbatim oh he's
on the same opening and says she's
looking at me like what's going on and
i'm like and i see him i go you did the
same exact thing and he was like yeah
it's kim and she's kind of even though
they're all about her there's a real
mother mother like chris
kim is like the matriarch of the did you
guys cover her fake ass
the fake ass photos from mexico no i
think i saw some of those oh well here's
the deal they always hire their own
paparazzi and the paparazzi pretends to
just
casually catch them taking pictures but
in mexico there was real paparazzi
waiting along with their fake paparazzi
so their fake paparazzi takes the photos
and then they edit them and they smooth
out all the cellulite and all that who
doesn't have it i mean yeah i mean it's
a normal human part of human especially
if you have a big fat ass like that it's
made of fat but it's it's a fake fat ass
and it's super obvious in the new
pictures look at this really yeah get
your life cut that's the real one like
look at the ones on the left like where
in life would you have that's a tumor
right right right
it's a full diaper yes yeah
it's a full diaper it totally is yeah i
mean her legs are so scrawny and then
she has this giant it's enormous but so
what they would do with photoshop is
stretch out the thigh to meet the ass so
it doesn't look so [ __ ] so is this
like a yeah that's that one doctored
yeah see the difference yeah the
doctored ones they make it look less
preposterous right but the real one it
just looks like cheese it's hilarious
gross it's like
it's just a like that what the [ __ ] is
that what is that what do you do in your
ass it's so gross we started to look for
dads that get excited about things you
know like that we consider him in that
category and like so like there's you
know what foamers are
no foamers are people that get like it's
not dirty really into trains
and they like will wait at train
stations for trains to drive by and they
[ __ ] get really excited why they call
them foamers
new york once again
on the snc
yeah
some train coming here southbound
on north creek they get really into it
man
[Music]
wow that's cool
well that sounds
what
what my gosh
[Music]
oh my god it sounds like an alco
oh
a 1943
s2
wow harry changed the clubman of the snc
[Music]
wow
look at that
she's a beauty
oh oh it's a
bl2 oh
man
yeah
snc carrick's all the way
so these guys just will wait for trains
like hours to fall train yeah he's so
excited about that train we're so
excited but don't you kind of envy this
guy's ability to get super stoked on
something so dumb no that guy needs to
find [ __ ] yeah because he's somebody he
would just abandon all those numbers he
keeps rattling that's f45
i've also had guys that are like
marginal headliners and you know working
comics just show up
just show up at my show and ask to do a
guest set
at like the chicago theater that's crazy
i'm not kidding yeah 3 700 people hey
i'd like to do a guest set hey i'd like
you to go [ __ ] yourself yeah be crazy
tell them what do you say no i go dude
this is all set up yeah like this guy's
gonna do 20. uh you know he's got ian's
going to do 20. tony hinchcliffe's going
to do 20. and then i'm doing an hour and
10. like this is what it is this is the
show like there's no room for your guest
set yeah i'll just do like seven minutes
no you're not doing anything i don't
even know what you're doing yeah i don't
know what kind of what if you go up on
stage and you start doing my my subject
yeah like get the [ __ ] out of here i
just got an email about theater one for
a theater show where they're like okay
but here's the thing would you ever do
that never never that's the thing like
imagine showing up at a like there's a
if you're a musician there's a band
playing like hey man i just like to go
home and do a song with you yeah the
[ __ ] [ __ ] mind well the crazy thing
about this email too because i've had
this a few times is it's an email saying
hey you're coming to this city
i'd love to do a set
not only do you not know who i am
i will provide no link to anything so
that you could check out like in other
words it's just sight unseen you don't
know anything about me can i be on your
show or the no and can i do like 20
minutes yeah that's that's nice
no i thought maybe like five i had a guy
show up in atlanta and he wanted to do a
half hour how much he said that yeah he
said you want to do that crazy he goes
uh he goes i want to do a guest set he
goes i'm only talking like 30 minutes
not like an hour
i remember when he's talking you know at
least they got a hustle though you know
i love dan godfrey he used to run the
break at improv and now he like oversees
i think all the improvs yeah and one
time i was in uh brea
and i was i think man i want to say i
was
middling this is like
uh probably like oh six or something and
the
but i was oh i was uh yeah i was
middling and the mc was like i'll do
turn to him i was like i'll do 20 and uh
and then him and then dan goes you'll do
10. he won't do a minute more like just
straight up because the guy was like
announcing
how much time he was going to do from
the mc's
20. yeah he was like i'll do 20 and then
how much do you do he's like you'll do
10 and not a second more
jennifer lopez has a legit latina ass
[Music]
[Music]
you